so good I'm like because I insisted they
over trained every single fire in my
career apart from that one and I said oh
I'll learn from this I'll learn from
this and you don't and it's like Jason
brillo always says it takes confidence
to take a day off to rest the body you
know you know and now of course there's
a fine line between having the
confidence to take a day off and being a
lazy bastard and saying I'm gonna sit on
the couch today right you know but even
believe you know listen I'm good
I'm gonna take a day or two off because
I need it you know so that was one of
the mistakes I made with my career I
always trained too much and Jason said
you know I used to mindfuck myself
because it meant so much to me you know
my fight career it meant so much to I
used to overcomplicate it overanalyze
the overworked it stress myself out with
it you know and that would that was
hindering my performances you know I
never once fought to the to my ability
of what I performed in the gym never
once I remember one day I pulled up
outside Ruka and Jason was waiting for
me outside and I pulled up and he says
Mike come here
can we have a quick chat I said yeah
what's up he said listen bud you go guys
in there okay he said but you're a
[ __ ] world champion can you go in
there and spar these guys and act like a
world champion down here you're up there
act like it don't go in lose your
[ __ ] temper spaz out stress out out
like a dick say things you regret you
know when the spine is not quite
necessarily going your way you know you
get a little pissed off or whatever you
know say jiu-jitsu coach he's catching
you and tapping you out a little bit you
start getting a little frustrated say
can you just you know can we have none
of that place and great advice just like
when I was fighting for the belt when I
flew home from doing that movie I went
straight to the gym when I landed and
Jason said to me because I was always
stressed you know and he said listen we
don't know if you're gonna win this
fight Mike you know fingers cry by
believing now believe you're gonna win
this fight but we don't know if you're
gonna win this fight so this might be
the only time you're ever gonna fight
for a world title right I said well yeah
possible he said well let's enjoy the
process you know let's go through
this with a smile on your face he said
this is huge
he said you're in a position that
everyone what it would kill to be in
you're fighting for the championship
you're fighting for the belt you've
wanted this whole this your whole life
enjoy this you know
aníbal such amazing advice because I was
like yeah you're right and I went
through the whole thing with a big smile
on my face and when you clip rock